اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش كالعاده ابرز
ملفات اليوم وفي ملفاته هذا المساء اسرار
جديده تكشفها وزيره فرنسيه سابقه عن محكمه
اغتيال الحريري اهمها ان دمشق متورطه
وضغطت لعدم الكشف عن دورها ما طبيعته هذه
الضغوط ولماذا خضعت لها المحكمه في الملف
الثاني اشتباكات حدوديه هنديه صينيه هل هي
مجرد حادثه عربيه ام اختبار فرديه
جديده وفي الملف الثالث اضرابات واسعه
النطاق في بريطانيا الصحه والنقله فهل
يحقق الاضراب اهدافها بزياده الوجور ام
ياتي في نتائج عكسيه على حقوق العمال
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من التفاصيل في تصريحات خاصه
للعربيه ذكرت وزيره الدفاع الفرنسيه
السابقه في برنامج ذاكره السياسيه الذي
سيتم بث حلقاته في وقت لاحقه ذكرت ان
شخصيه من النظام السوري متورطه في جريمه
اغتيال رئيس الحكومه اللبنانيه الاسبق
رفيق الحريري وان المحكمه الدوليه الخاصه
قبيل لبنان تعرضت لضغوط كبيره لتبديل
قرارها النهائي وحصر الجرائم بعناصره من
حزب الله وحده
التونسيه
السوريه
او كما اعتقدت القياده الفرنسيه
ولكن لماذا
حقيقي
وسيله
هذا سؤال تحديدا من اراد ان يحمي النظام
السوري القيادات على الاقل التي تورطت
اذا النظام السوري
لكي تشطب اسماء بعض قياداتها المتورطه
كلمه مصري فيديو
[موسيقى]
سنبقى في متابعه وانتظار هذه الحلقات الجد
مهمه من الذاكره السياسيه تقديم زميل طاهر
بركه
نناقش هذه الجزئيه مع ضيوفي من دمشق عبد
الحميد توفيق الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بيك من
بيروت محمد حجار نائب سابق في طيران
المستقبل اهلا بكم ضيوف الكرام اسمحوا لي
ان ابدا من بيروت معك سيد محمد في الواقع
ميشيل اليوم اخي وزيره الدفاع الفرنسيه
سابقا
اكدت من خلال هذه المقابله همم بان هناك
اسماء بعينها تم الغاءها او على الاقل عدم
طرحها بضغوطات من جهات معينه والمحت في
هذه المقابله الى النظام السوري هل تعتقد
حضرتك بان للنظام السوري القدره على الضغط
على مثل هكذا محكمه بهذا المستوى نتحدث عن
قضيه دوليه ومحكمه دوليه وما الاليات التي
يمكن ان يضغط بها
يعني انا طبعا يعني لا لا يعني انا لا
املك هكذا معطيات لاعلم او لاجاوب على هذا
السؤال يعني ما هي الطريقه التي تتناول
بها النظام في سوريا
كيف فعل كيف عمل
يا استاذ محمد اتحدث عن
هل لديه القدره مهما كانت الاليه ومهما
كانت الطريقه لديه القدره لديه الاليات
الفعليه للضغط النظام السوري
يعني لست انا من من يقول ذلك لست انا من
يقول ذلك ولا ازعم بانني اعلم او يملك
معطيات حول ذلك ولكن من قال بهذا القول هو
وزير الدفاع فرنسيه سابقا وزيرا الدفاع
لدوله عظمى للرجال الدفاع لدوله عضو دائم
في مجلس الامن الدولي وهي وهي في ذاك
الوقت كانت تبلغ لا شك المعطيات عندما
كانت في في في تحمل هذه الحقيبه وتمارس
وتمارس مهمك وزيره الدفاع لا شك بان يتوفر
لديها مجموعه من المعلومات التي جعلتها
تقول ما قالته وبالشكل العلني الذي سمعته
على
العربيه يعني همم ليس الشخصي عادي
دوله اوروبيه كبيره طيب استاذ عبد الحميد
لماذا من شان اليوم ماغي وزيره الدفاع
الفرنسيه السابقه تضع في دائره هامه
النظام السوري بالقول بان هذا النظام قد
يكون ضغط
لمحاوله الغاء طرح اسماء قالت بانه كانت
هناك اسماء وتم الغاءها او تم شطبها همم
ولم يتم حتى التحقيق بخصوصها لم تتوفر
دلائل لانه كانت هناك ضغوطات من الاساس
لعدم الضغط لمحاوله ايجادلاء اللازمه
همم
اعتقد بان همم الدوافع الكامنه وراء مثل
هذا التصريح
لوزيره الدفاع الفرنسيه السابقه في هذه
المرحله همم مثيره للاستفهام من ناحيتين
الاولى لماذا لم تتحدث وهي على راسي وزاره
الدفاع حين كانت همم مسؤوله ووزير رسميه
في تلك المرحله اذا كانت تتحلى بالشفافيه
وتتحلى بالالتزام وتتحلى بتمثل القيم التي
يتحدثون عنها في الغرب ويتتحلى ايضا
بالقيم القانونيه التي تعتمدها المحاكم
الجنائيه او المحاكم الدوليه الامر الاخر
الذي يثير الاستفهام ايضا من جانبه وجهه
نظر الان تطرح هذه الطروحات وكانها تريد
ان تقول باننا كنا عاجزين عن وضع السياق
القانوني والنتائج المحاكمات الدوليه
الجنائيه في اطارها الصحيح اذا حماه تدعيه
وزيره الدفاع الفرنسيه السابقه في انها
الجانب السوري تمكن من شطر اسماء بعض
المتهمين السوريين في يمكن ان نقول بان
سوريا في تلك المرحله كانت قوه عظمى كيف
ان اتسائل انا كمواطن سوري كيف يمكن ان ان
تكون هذه الحادثه قد حدثت بحجم اغتيال
الراحل رفيق الحريري وما احدثته منذ 2005
الى الان في المنطقه وفي لبنان وفي المحيط
العربي من همم
قلاقل وما احدثته من تحولات وتغيرات
وتقلبات في التيارات السياسيه وحتى في
الدول ما ترتب على ذلك في تلك المرحله في
ليسان 2005 بعد حوالي شهر ونص تقريبا من
حادثه الاغتيال اكثر حتى انسحاب الجيش
السوري من لبنان اعتقد بان مثل هذه
الطروحات الان يرادوا منها فقط
التبرير او محاوله التنصر من المسؤوليه
كانت اساسا
فقط سيد عبد الحميد
همم مش انا اليوماغي وزيره الدفاع
الفرنسيه سابقه لم تكون الاولى صحيح بانها
همم وزيره همم كانت ترئه وزاره السياديه
ولكن همم قبل هي كان هناك قاضي سويسري
يدعى روبرتو همم قاضي سويسري اشتغل على
هذه القضيه بين 2011 و 2013 وهو نفسه قال
نفس هذا الكلام من فتره قال بانه كانت
هناك اسماء موضوعه لتحقيق معها وسمى حتى
ااه بشار الاسد همم رئيس سوري وقال بانه
كانت هناك ضغوطات وهو نفسه تلقى ضغوطات
للي يتخلى عن هذا المنصب استقال هو قال
بانه استقلت باني يهودي وكانت هناك
انتقادات بخصوص هذا الموضوع فلم تكون
الانتقادات الاولى لماذا ندور في هذا
الاطار بالعوده دائما النظام السوري
باختصار حتى انقل نفس هذا السؤال الاستاذ
محمد
انا اعتقد سؤال جوهري حقيقه لماذا ندور في
اعاده الانتقاد لهذه الحادثه اعود الى هذه
الدائره لاقول بان ما يحدث الان سواء
انتقاد القاضي السابق او وزيره الدفاع
الفرنسيه او الحديث هي لم تنتقد بل تحدث
عن وجود الضغوط الا انا اتسائل بهذه بهذه
لماذا يعد بحث هذا الملف
بشكل
لماذا يطرح
مره طالما ان هناك ضغوطات لماذا لم
دمه الدول او الشخصيات اول الاطراف او
التيارات التي مارس الضغوطها وهل يعقل لاي
عاقل هل يعقل ان يقبل اي عاقل ان تكون
محكمه جنائيه دوليه بهذا الحجم ومشكل من
مجلس الامن الدولي ان تخضع لضغوطات لا
يحددون جهتهم
نعم يمكن ان تخضع لان هذه المحكمه هي
محكمه مسيسه هي محكمه سياسيه همم ليست
بهذا الطابع القانوني كما يتوقع البعض
خليني اخذ رايك استاذ محمد في هذا الاطار
كانت هناك او لطالما كانت هناك دائما همم
لديك تعليق قبل سؤاله استاذ محمد
يعني لا طبعا يعني اقول بانه يعني قالت ما
قالته زياده الدفاع الفرنسيه السابقه
ودعيني اقول بان ما قالته يتلاقى مع رؤيا
مع مفهوم مع قراءه كانت موجوده لدى العالم
كله ليس فقط نحن التيار المستقبل في ذاك
الوقت او نحن كان لبنانيين في ذكر الوقت
اغتيال الرئيس الشهيد رفيق الحريري الكل
يعلم بان رفيق الحريري كان شخصيه
تجاوزت بكثير الوطن اللبناني لنذهب
لتكون بحجم الوطن العربي الى بل بحجم
عالمي والكل يشهد بذلك وقال له وقال مقاله
في هذا الصدد همم ضيفك ضيفك من سوريا
السؤال الذي يطرح هو همم هو ما قالته
وزيره الدفاع الفرنسيه والذي يتلاقى مع
هذه القراءه التي كانت لدى الكثير من
المتابعين ان كان في الان امن اللبنانيين
امفي العالم العربي ام في هذا العالم كله
في ظل المتابعه الدولي حول دور سوري
ايراني في عمليه اغتيال الرئيس الشهيد
رفيق الحريري لانه لا يمكن ل- اا لاغتيال
جريمه اغتيال بهذه الضخامه وبهذا الحجم
لشخصيه بحجم رفيق الحريري ان تكون مره كما
ذكرت المحكمه نفذ من قبل العناصر من حزب
الله لا يمكن ان نكون همم الحزب قد قام
بهذه العمليه
وتم التحضير لها بهذا الشكل بدون علم
المخابرات السوريه التي كانت موجوده على
مساحه
هذا تحليل ولكن الواقع قد يكون مغاير
معك يا استاذ محمد بانه صحيح ولكن خليني
افطر معك بانه هناك علاقه طالما نحن في
حضور او في حضره تصريحات رسميه همم لو
الدفاع سابقه ولا طالما كانت هناك وكان
هناك يقين في لبنان في داخل لبنان بتورق
نظام بشار الاسد وايران من خلفه باختيال
رفيق الحريري طيب ولكن كما كانت او كان
للنظام السوري القدره على الضغط لماذا لم
يتابع لبنان لم يستمر لبنان همم في محاوله
ايجاد همم حقيقه على الاقل تقنعه او تقنع
عقله وتفكيره في كيف تمت العمليه ومن
وراءها
يعني تتعلمين السيده سيده ريما وكل
هذا الاعلام وكل الامن من من تابع هذه
الجريمه انك رافدك الوقت يعلم حجم الضغوط
التي مورست على لبنان والتي بورست على
الحكومه اللبنانيه في ذاك الوقت التي كان
يراس الرئيس فؤاد السنيوره حجم الضغوط
الذي وصل الى حد استقاله مجموعه من مجموعه
كبيره من الوزراء في محاوله لافقاد
الحكومه مجلس الوزراء النظام القانوني لكي
يتمكن من تحت اي قرار حجم الضغوط الذي
مرسي لمنع قبول لبنان او منع طلب لبنان
بلاش باحكي دوليه لتبحث في عمليه في هذه
لتحاكم من قام ونفذ وخطط لهذه الجريمه همم
طلبا للحقيقه التي كنا نريدها حقيقه بل
قام بذلك وان ينال العقاب الذي يستحقه
لاستمرار جرائم الاغتيال السياسيه في
لبنان لا بل في اي منطقه من هذا العالم
العربي عندما يقول هنا عندما يكون القاتل
معروف ومجهول في نفس الوقت والحقيقه ضائعه
هذا يشجع الكثير على القيام بهذا العمليه
نحن كنا ننشد الحقيقه ولا شيء غير الحقيقه
وقلنا باننا نثق بالمحكمه الدوليه ومازلنا
نفق بالمحكمه الدوليه ونحن لا نشكك بما
قالته وزيره الدفاع الفرنسيه ولكن المطلوب
اليوم بتقديري من المحكمه الدوليه التي
نثق بها ان تقول رايها في هذا الموضوع ان
توضح ان تعلق على ما قالته وزيره الدفاع
للحقيقه التي يعلمها الجميع هل تعتقد
استاذ عبد الحميد بانه المحكمه الدوليه
ستعلق على هكذا تصريحات وبانه لهذه
التصريحات ستكون بدايه و خطوه اولى نحو
ليست تحقيق تحقيق تم والحكم صدر ولكن نحو
الكشف
جزئيات اخرى تعتقد
بان الافتراض المنطقي يقول بان عليها ان
تعلق عليها ان تستجوب هذه الوزيره لكي
تفصح عن اوراقها التي ارادت ان ان تضعها
في اطار النسبيات قد اعتقد وما قد وقد
قرات بدقه ومن اكثر من جهه قراته ما قالته
هذه الوزيره اعتقد بانه الاختيار الاول
والمنطقي واحترام القانون واحترام عقل
الانسان ان تذهب هذه المحكمه لتسال هذه
الوزيره وتستدعيها بما هي فيه هذا جانب
والجانب الاخر اعتقد بان الاعتراف بان
السياسه هي التي همم حرفت هذه المحكمه كما
يقولون عن مجراها القانوني ومجراها جنائي
الدلالي اعتقد بانها ستفعل فعلها ايضا في
هذا الاطار ولكن اعود الى السؤال حقيقه
انا استغرب ايضا ان يطلق كثير من المسلمين
الغربيه اعتن عليهما ان يطلق هكذا مواقف
بعد ان يتنحو من مناصيبهم او يبتعدوا او
يصبحوا في في المنازل
كوني هذه التصريحات بقيه سنتبعها وشكركم
جزيلا شكرا على مشاركتنا هذا النقاش من
دمشق عبد الحميد توفيق الكاتب الصحفي ومن
بيروت محمد حجار نائب سابق في طيران
المستقبل شكرا لكم